I spent a lot of time thinking about how
I want to wrap up PAX West 2016 how I
want to encapsulate the experience and
I'm not entirely sure maybe it's just
that my brain is so abused by the 28
hours I spent driving there and back the
cumulative 9 or 10 hours spent waiting
in various lines 3 to 4 hours just
walking back and forth from the
convention hall and the remaining hours
spent walking the convention floor
the density of doing to waiting is so
thin that if it weren't for the constant
barrage of loud noises and bright lights
pax would be par with a sensory
deprivation tank even in the moment it
becomes so steady and constant that it
veers into the meaningless a hypnotic
white noise that is immediately
forgotten like the sound of tires on
pavement we mentally survive boredom by
erasing it from our memories sensory
information comes in is found wanting
and is instantly thrown out as a result
boredom isn't really something we
remember or to put it another way we
don't remember boredom as much as we
remember being bored it's a detached
observational memory a third party
summary of our own past state rather
than a recollection of a formerly
present state of mind
once you tally up preparation and travel
I spent 6 hours of my life just to spend
15 minutes with a virtual reality tech
demo of a Rick and Morty game that
doesn't currently exist and I mean that
in the most incisive sense I can the bit
of gameplay that was on display wasn't
actually on display you could only see
it by participating and all the screens
that allow the presenters to monitor the
players experience were turned at angles
that prevented Outsiders from catching
more than a glimpse here and there of
what was going on the whole of it staged
to limit future memory and impede
recollection the gameplay involved was
pure proof of concept could something
like this conceivably work within the
framework of Rick and Morty's humor it's
not only possible but highly probable
the bit I played won't even be in the
future game should it even get made so
for all that waiting I got to see an
outline of a thing that might exist and
a commemorative pin after I recounted
that story Daniel Floyd of extra credits
asked me the most natural question
imaginable was it worth it and I don't
know I don't know because I don't
remember the hours of standing in line
have been compressed into single point
memories that no longer hold any weight
it's not a bad time it's just time that
has effectively vanished
from Calgary Southwest to the Crowsnest
past West to ferny and Cranbrook south
to East port bonners ferry pend oreille
and Spokane West to sprog Ritz Ville
Ellensburg and into Seattle from Seattle
north through Linwood Everett Mount
Vernon Abbotsford East to Chilliwack
Bridal Falls and hope north to maraton
Kamloops East to Salmon Arm
SiC a moose Revelstoke Golden Banff and
at long last Sun long set in to Calgary
I've passed through all of this I know
this because the evidence says I clearly
must have but the spaces in between are
gone now in the end the tens of minutes
I spent catching up with friends
chatting about the state of online media
with other video producers and dinner
with some new friends of the Cheesecake
cafe these are the things that I'm more
likely to retain these are the things
that PACs will likely become in my
memories are 45 minutes of good
conversation worth 28 hours of driving
what if you'll barely remember them
content-wise I suppose pax was fine I'm
not sure because I ignored the vast
majority of it there's already so much
standing in line for the things I would
like to see or do or collect that I
really can't be bothered to stand in
line for things I'm at best passively
curious about whether that waiting will
be ejected for memory or not part of
this is that I'm generally more
interested in the overall trends what
are the repeating patterns the running
themes across the convention as a whole
the other part is that the big-name
demos are a bit of a scam the incentives
are all set up to cheat everyone
creators and audience of authenticity
like a dating site where everyone picks
their best photo and lists their flaws
is caring too much and loving too deeply
the convention floor is only friendly to
the shallowest safest easiest to digest
presentation packed into a capsule that
will allow you to process as many bodies
as possible in a limited period of time
spectacle in and of itself isn't
entirely without merit but it suffers
harsh diminishing returns there's only
so many times you can pass the giant
branded dinosaur statue before it stops
being a wonder and becomes a convenient
landmark between the merch booth and the
skybridge virtual reality was
predictably the capital letters big
thing this year it's interesting over
the years watching VR slowly get better
and sit now on the cusp of actually
being good it's still young but slowly
everyone is working out the kinesthetic
dialect of virtual reality along with
the
sanitary logistics of sharing a VR
headset with hundreds of people per day
for the next couple of generations of VR
though the big experience of the matrix
you'll be replicating is having a giant
cable hanging off the back of your head
I can't help but feel a sense of irony
in that following in the footsteps of
the Wiis motion controls and the kinect
and adding almost a decade of
improvements the vive and oculus aim to
free players from the constraints of the
couch allowing them to not just wave
their arms at their television but to
walk around realized immersive fictional
spaces only to then be tethered to
reality by a literal tether of cables
virtual reality is increasingly
impressive but the scenes show quickly
as practical issues rear their head you
put on the headset and you are free to
walk around anywhere anywhere that is
within an 8-foot cube as you approach
the edge you're confronted with a grid
marking the edge of the playable area a
handy guide for preventing you from
breaking things or hurting yourself but
a sudden reminder of the disconnect
between perceived space and the actual
distances in one demo I repeatedly
punched a cloth wall while trying to
pick up a fake paint can off a virtual
shelf sitting against the edge of the
simulated world the reality of virtual
reality is that we're still trying to
figure out the best way of going
somewhere while not going very far it's
the middle space between standard
control dialects and augmented reality
like Pokemon go if you want to go
somewhere in no man's sky you sit in
your chair and push forward on the
controls if you want to go somewhere in
Pokemon go you get up move your body
there so how do we move our bodies a
little bit without needing to move our
bodies too far and how do we translate
that into a meaningful expression in the
virtual space incidentally Seattle is
rich with machop with nary an oddish to
be seen is it strange that one of the
things I'm most excited to bring home is
a fighting-type pokémon that can
challenge the Dragonite we've lured 420
leaves of the gym down the street one of
the best dimensions of packs of any con
really is the cosplay not just for the
spectacular craftsmanship and creativity
on display but because it gives you a
sense of what's connecting with people
what are the characters the outlines the
stories that they see themselves in or
that they want to inhabit to literally
embody as VR lets us swap our skin with
virtual bodies cosplayers rework virtual
bodies onto their skin
outside golden British Columbia is a
segment of highway a twisted narrow
stretch of road that clings to the edge
of the mountains as it winds up and down
the size of the Kicking Horse Canyon
this is the highway you've been driving
with me but the one you're seeing isn't
the one I remember the highway was
terrible with brutally sharp turns
narrow shoulders and insufficient guards
access to the town was routinely cut off
as chunks of road would slide off into
the river below workers spent ten years
chiseling improvements out of the
mountain widening the berth shoring up
the walls and abandoning stretches in
favour of a brand new bridge and road
blasted out of the rock as you drive it
if you know what you're looking for you
can see fragments of the old road bits
and chunks of abandoned blacktop but
it's almost impossible now to really
remember what the old road looked like
what it felt like to take its sharp
corners stuck in a narrow lane will a
tanker truck past going the other way
I remember that highway but I don't I
remember it viscerally I remember how it
felt even as the path the dips and
curves and exact placement fades years
back I spent time in Australia where I
took a road trip from Brisbane down to
Sydney I spent several days with my
Australian friends coaching me through
the process of relearning how to drive
how to be confident reversing one's
instincts of which shoulder to check
over and remembering which hand
triggered the indicator in which hand
turned on the wipers logically I know I
drove on the left hand side for the
entire trip for Brisbane through port
McCurry and down to Sydney because that
is actually the way that Australians
drive but it's not the way I remember it
after I returned home to Canada and
reacquainted myself with right hand
driving going through many of the same
mistakes with the wipers and the signals
my visual memories began to morph the
snippets of highway that haven't been
erased have all been reversed when I
visualized cruising through Gold Coast
on a drizzly November afternoon it's all
flipped I'm sitting on the left-hand
side of the car going down the
right-hand side of the road I still turn
left out of my apartment to get to
Hungry Jack's but now in my mind I turn
left from the right-hand lane I'm not
entirely sure how I want to encapsulate
this year's packs experience because I'm
still not quite sure what this year's
packs experience will turn out to be
there is what it was standing in lines
playing demos people watching good
conversations pin trading walking
getting rained on getting depressed
getting excited
enjoying Seattle and pining for Calgary
but how much of that will translate into
what it will be a week or a month from
now the impressions that are handed out
are inherently suspect delicately
curated for maximum impact and devoid of
the messy charms of a more engaged
experience many border on illusory
apparitions that resemble the idea of a
future experience while containing
little if any of the ingredients that
experience will actually be made of they
are for good and ill roads that will be
paved over
you